é gente é uma honra estar aqui com vocês
hoje eu fui convidada para falar sobre
inovação social
e quando eu pensei por que que eu estava
sendo convidada pra isso eu me remontei
há dez anos atrás quando tinha 23 anos
de idade e tomei o que na época foi a
decisão mais difícil da minha vida eu
estava me formando em direito tinha
possibilidade para um escritório de
advocacia com salário de mercado
mestrado pago e alguns outros benefícios
e do outro lado tinha oportunidade de
pôr uma ong internacional trabalhar com
ela a liderança de jovens morar com
outras sete pessoas tenham um quarto do
que ganhariam no escritório trabalhar
com essas sete pessoas num ambiente
bastante caótico
é claro que eu fiz a segunda opção e não
me arrependo foi uma das melhores coisas
que eu fiz na minha vida entre outras
coisas
essa decisão me deu oportunidade de
viajar para a índia por exemplo
e quando viajei pra índia eu na época
reúne as milhas da família inteira
fiquei na índia na casa de um amigo de
um amigo que era indiano e que me ajudou
a ver todas as sensações né porque ainda
não é só ver é sentir cheirar é tudo é e
lá também pôde participar de uma
conferência dessa organização que reuniu
600 outros jovens para pensar o futuro
para onde a gente quer ir e construir
isso junto
no momento que foi considerado muito
importante para várias coisas que se
seguiram e de quebra ainda na volta
aproveitei a conexão do vôo para dar uma
paradinha na holanda e visitar o meu
amigo e mentor márcio e que morava na
época é na holanda e também pode me dar
um pouquinho do que é e se essa vida de
holandesa é no dia a dia passando rápido
aos seis anos
é eu tive a oportunidade é ditar uma
orientação muito maior
essa organização é muito maior me dava
muito mais estrutura para trabalhar é do
que onde eu estava antes e várias coisas
foram-se seguindo e foram bastante
naturais é eu continuava trabalhando com
uma coisa que eu acreditava que era
sustentabilidade e te fato a gente
conseguiu realizar alguma coisa algumas
coisas bastante importantes na época a
gente fez um programa é relevante com os
fornecedores da organização onde a gente
entendia onde estavam os problemas de
produção de comunicação de estoque e de
sustentabilidade ea razão pela qual
coloquei uma grama aqui é porque já um
dos primeiros projetos a gente conseguiu
reverter 90 por cento de resíduos de
borracha de uma fábrica para transformar
em grama sintética e deixa a molecada
jogar bola
a gente também conseguiu duplicar um
programa é pós consumo é que evitou ano
ano mais ou menos 5 mil carros populares
em aço é de estar em ambiente de sucata
e voltarem ao ciclo produtivo programa
de redução de água e energia em fábricas
que reduziram por exemplo o consumo de
água é correspondente a uma cidade de
150 mil habitantes por um ano só com
ações simples e gestão nem olhar esses
números e também a expandir programas
importantes de relacionamento com a
comunidade para vários países onde a
gente estava presente e criar um
programa específico onde a gente
perguntava para as pessoas da comunidade
qual é o seu sonho é o que vai fazer a
diferença aqui e aí mobilizava um grupo
grande de 400 500 voluntários também
várias partes do mundo para realizar
esses sonhos no final de semana mas se
isso era tudo muito legal tinha algumas
coisas que não estavam mais batendo
tanto
uma delas é esse ambiente aqui que vocês
estão vendo que é a sala vip do
aeroporto de frankfurt na alemanha
é ela é muito bonita é muito legal tem
internet
tem comida tem a linha de massagem e
tudo mas se você olhar nas nas fotos é
nenhuma pessoa estava feliz né nenhuma
pessoa está lá se conectando nenhuma
pessoa está lá inteira e isso se reflete
em várias outras coisas se reflete no
hotel e pessoal que você fica se reflete
no restaurante internacional que você
vai que não tem aquele gosto de índia
holanda ou de joinville eo local do
local onde você tá é e também é e se
reflete nas relações que a gente tinha
com os próprios colegas que ficavam
muito restritas aos indicadores e tudo
mais
quando comentava isso com pessoas um
pouco mais tradicionais elas e olha isso
faz parte da vida é você cresceu ea vida
é assim está bom acho que eu consigo
conviver com isso e aí quando a gente
quando eu retornei
conversei com alguns colegas de
diferentes áreas a gente pensou a gente
já tem trabalhado bastante para melhorar
processos e relacionamentos
qual é o próximo passo é a gente atuava
no setor é que é responsável por 15% do
consumo de energia e era líder global de
vendas na nossa área e quando a gente
pensava a respeito é bastante óbvio que
esse tema de eficiência energética é um
tema muito importante e que para muito
além de ser líder de vendas a gente
tinha uma potencialidade de ser líder do
assunto né de trazer esse assunto para
trazer os maiores especialistas trazer
as maiores inovações é fazer apreensões
nem pelos de políticas públicas e como
melhorar a legislação nessas áreas para
realmente é levar esse tema por um outro
nível mas quando a gente conversava e
naquela situação especial
a resposta que esse grupo teve tal mas
como que isso gera dinheiro nesse
trimestre
eu fiquei pensando o mata nada dessas
coisas maiores mais importantes da vida
eu consigo planejar fazer resultado no
trimestre
não consigo plantar uma árvore no
trimestre escreveu um livro ter um filho
é abril empresa e fazê la funcionar
então ah não não funciona nem a coisa
não não vai pra frente
e se antes a sentença
então era de asas não é era de poder
apesar de ter pouquíssimos recursos é
tudo que a gente conseguisse imaginar
articular pessoas e fazer tudo é
possível
a sensação é que era um pouco essa caixa
né você tá dentro de uma caixa é e
precisa se adequar a ela e para mim o
que foi interessante é dada o que é o
castilho assim da mudança pra mim foi na
verdade uma proposta de uma caixa maior
ou pelo menos uma caixa mais equipada
nem com a em fire é internet computador
e tal é de ter assumido uma posição
ainda mais elevada numa uma outra
empresa ainda maior e tal e eu disse
olha será que é isso né
será que é isso e nesse momento então
bati um papo mais profundo é com o meu
marido que é o erick que é empreendedor
e não tem muito problema com um assumir
risco e agentes não vamos mudar de vida
vamos fazer é vamo investir na empresa
que ele já tinha e vamos tocar alguma
coisa diferente
aí eu chamei o márcio lado a holanda é e
mais um amigo que a gente tinha em comum
todo mundo mudou pra floripa ea gente
começou uma empresa que pretendia ajudar
prefeituras a ter políticas públicas e
principalmente serviços públicos
melhores nem um atendimento melhor ao
usuário final é trabalhamos alguns meses
em cima disso só que ops não deu certo
no tempo que a gente tinha com as
interações que a gente fez a gente não
conseguiu encontrar um modelo que
parasse de pé dentro das coisas que a
gente estava prevendo
e aí achei aquele outro momento difícil
né
será que eu fiz a coisa certa né será
que eu tomei a decisão certa porque
encaramos um negócio não dar certo e é
quando o henrique entrou na minha vida e
ele fala assim
sabe aquele risco que você correu
abrindo uma empresa nova e tal não quer
correr o risco bem maior
pegar dinheiro de outras pessoas ganham
um salário bem ruim e trabalhar num
setor que mal existe aqui em floripa
eu pensei pensei mais um pouquinho eu
sim sim sim e sim eu quero
e foi aí que a gente começou é o empate
rápido floripa que pretende ser esse
espaço é onde a gente apoia
empreendedores que querem criar um mundo
radicalmente melhor por meio dos seus
negócios com espaço físico para isso com
a educação como mentores e com uma rede
global e nesse contexto a gente resolveu
adotar todos aqueles princípios que a
gente acreditava que eram verdadeiros e
que eram possíveis entre eles sucesso é
igual a finanças saudáveis sim mas há
impacto positivo e eu posso dar certeza
pra vocês hoje que a gente gasta muito
mais tempo pensando em como melhorar o
impacto do que como melhorar as finanças
e que inclusive uma coisa ajuda a outra
a outra coisa que a gente adotou é que o
como importa muito
então a gente não quer a a apenas não é
fazer a apoiar empreendedores
socioambientais mas a gente quer fazer
isso de um jeito colaborativo em passar
por cima de ninguém e que a gente tem
orgulho da trajetória que a gente tenha
passado uma outra coisa muito importante
é essa de experimentar o futuro hoje
então se a gente quer é finanças e
recursos mais distribuídos se a gente
quer decisões mais colaborativas
a gente quer critérios diferentes para a
tomada de decisão como é que a gente faz
isso hoje a gente entende que a
aprendizagem acontece na prática e o
tempo todo então nada do que a gente faz
é teórico as referências são sempre
práticas e mão na massa
apesar de a gente ser um negócio com um
fim socioambiental o sonho não precisa
ser pequeno sonho pode ser grande então
se a gente encontra um modelo que faz
sentido o céu é o limite né lembra
sempre da asa ea gente também tem uma
uma potencialidade e ao mesmo tempo ser
um negócio muito local mas está
conectado com uma rede global que tem
outros 88 empate ramos como nós
espalhados no mundo inteiro com makes e
fundadores que são pessoas regional
áreas e principalmente com uma rede de
membros que também são empreendedores e
querem fazer a diferença
mas como é que isso acontece na prática
na prática mesmo né
bom antes de começar o empate rambi
antes de ter o espaço físico a gente já
começou a formar essa comunidade essa
rede
a gente criou o primeiro é um uma
espécie de membro virtual e um festival
de aprendizagem que acabou sendo maior
do brasil onde a gente já traiu é mais
de 500 pessoas participando de mais de
20 atividades diferentes sobre como
criar sua própria empresa como contar
melhores históricas
histórias como criar produtos por meio
do design thinking e vários outros
assuntos relacionados ao
empreendedorismo inovação e impacto
positivo a gente também escolheu um
espaço que tinha essa cara de inovação a
gente preferia um espaço é novo não
tentado é mais que metade ou mais da
área
são áreas comuns são áreas onde as
pessoas se encontram fazem reuniões e
esbarram em pessoas que elas não
esbarrariam a e que tem essa área de
aberto de colorido de inovador e tudo
mais
se é pra ter recursos distribuídos a
gente decidiu ser a quarta empresa do
brasil ea primeira fora de são paulo e o
primeiro negócio é social a usar o e
claudevan dem para levantar o dinheiro
que a gente precisava para abrir o nosso
negócio
o e cláudio pando é uma nova forma é de
financiamento para está p's onde ao
invés de você ter um investidor anjo ou
um fundo tecban cantando
são várias as pessoas que colocam
ticktes menores para viabilizar o seu
negócio
no nosso caso foram 57 investidores que
colocaram entre mil e 10 mil reais e
isso foi mais de 70% de todo o
investimento que a gente precisou para
tirar o negócio do papel
ainda falando de colaboração é pra fazer
o espaço acontecer
ao invés da o bric para o arquiteto ele
fazer um projeto agente implementar a
gente fez uma coisa um pouco mais
difícil a gente
quarenta pessoas que queriam ocupar o
espaço que eram alinhadas conosco que
eram membros para pensar conosco como
deveria ser esse espaço
a gente partiu do impacto que a gente
quer gerar em floripa e pensou qual é o
espaço que mais favorece isso para todos
nós e terminamos o dia com maquetes e aí
depois os arquitetos e nós mesmos
tivemos a tarefa de traduzir essas
maquetes essas vontades é pra um plano
técnico é e viável
a gente também é com isso é um elemento
central do da nossa proposta tem um
escritório colaborativo é que têm todas
as coisas que o produtor precisa entre
elas internet boa e café né
mas algumas outras coisas e que também
não tem coisas que não são importantes
como paredes e coisas desse tipo
reuniões obrigatórias e tudo mais é e
essas essas interações falta de paredes
e alguns movimentos provocados começam a
gerar um nível de produtividade e
colaboração bastante impressionante
toda segunda feira de manhã a gente tem
o réu me auto que é um bate papo com sul
com café para as pessoas dizerem quais
são as suas prioridades e qual é o meu
principal desafio para o qual eu preciso
de ajuda
e aí a gente lembra que são em pé
pessoas de empresas diferentes e é muito
raro a gente sair de um home altos em um
conteúdo sem um contato ou sem alguém
dizendo que vai nos ajudar a resolver o
nosso problema
isso tudo gera muitos negócios e muita
movimentação entre os próprios membros
essa foto é de uma relação cliente
fornecedor mas além disso a gente já
teve membro trocando serviço cinco
sessões de coaching por arrumar o meu
site ou a membros juntando as suas
propostas de valor para fazer uma
proposta maior e mais elaborada com uma
margem melhor e tal para o cliente
externo mas a gente também aproveitar
esse espaço não só para gerar relação
entre os membros mas também para atrair
a pessoas que não freqüentam o espaço
todo dia
o que a gente tem chamado de super
eventos pelo menos uma vez por mês a
gente tem algo para mais de 300 pessoas
que fomentam o ecossistema entre esses
eventos a gente já teve o próprio
técnico floripa sendo realizado há é as
escolas hospitais de tecnologia eventos
de design e assim por diante
e como a gente não estava satisfeito com
o impacto que a gente estava gerando a
gente ainda se engajou num programa é
para apoiar 97 empreendedores de impacto
97 empreendedores sociais que a gente
identificou na grande florianópolis
isso como por meio de cursos mentores
individuais consultorias técnicas e
rodas de aprendizado que eles fazem
entre eles a praça apoiar tanto técnica
prática e emocionalmente
o mais legal de tudo isso é que a gente
não a gente não se sente sozinho a a
gente tem esses 97 empreendedores que
estão nessa rede
a gente tem 11 mil membros do ramo no
mundo inteiro a relacionados ao empate
rubi com essa proposta é ea gente vê
dado após dado que demonstra que as
pessoas querem estar em ambientes
colaborativos
a previsão é que daqui a cinco anos 40%
das pessoas sejam ou empreendedoras ou
autônomas e que até 2025 economia
colaborativa se multiplique por 22
então como me sinto hoje é conseguindo
viver vários desses princípios que já
faziam sentido pra mim há dez anos atrás
quando eu tinha 23 anos
é mas com uma estrutura muito melhor
porque eu acho que hoje é muito melhor é
muito mais fácil você empreender a gente
tem muito mais apoio para empreender a
gente tem muito mais ferramentas e e
acesso a ferramentas de software de
internet e várias outras coisas
é inclusive tá nesse nesse setor de
negócios sociais que tende a estourar no
bom sentido e além disso com dez anos a
mais de experiência para conseguir tomar
algumas decisões um pouquinho mais
espertos e cometeu um pouco menos de
erros e com isso na prática o que eu
consigo ter é vários dos meus amigos se
relacionando comigo no dia a dia
o margen um dos principais parceiros
nesse programa de negócios sociais o
henry continua com o meu sócio
o erick me apoiando no dia a dia e
principalmente aí uma nova figura que é
o max que agora tem dois anos esse
sorriso livro é que vai no ramo e toda
semana é e ver a mãe dele trabalhando
com uma coisa que ela acredita que vai
fazer a diferença
então é isso gente muito obrigada é uma
honra estar aqui com vocês